S
AND PRAYERS ALONE ARE NOT
ENOUGH.
WE NEED ACTION.
>> Sean: JOINING US NOW WITH
MORE AS THE TEXAS SENATOR
HIMSELF TED CRUZ.
I LOVE THAT LINE, I'M NOT GOING
TO APOLOGIZE FOR THOUGHTS OR
PRAYERS NOR WILL HE WILL
APOLOGIZE FOR THE RIGHT OF THE
PEOPLE TO KEEP AND BEAR ARMS AND
PROTECT THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILY, THANK YOU FOR STANDING
UP FOR OUR CONSTITUTION AND THE
SECOND AMENDMENT BECAUSE
APPARENTLY MANY ARE NOT AN
JOE BIDEN IS THREATENING
EXECUTIVE ACTION.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT AND THE
MODERN-DAY LEFT AS MORE AND MORE
EXTREME.
THEY HAD THIS BIZARRE AND TO GOD
YOUR PRAYERS.
THE FIRST THING YOU DO WHEN
SOMEONE HAS LOST A LOVED ONE AS
YOU REACH OUT AND SAY I'M
LIFTING YOU UP IN PRAYER, AND
PRAYING FOR YOU, YOUR FAMILY, I
KNOW YOUR HURTING AND MAY GOD'S
PEACE BE WITH YOU IN THE LEFT
TREATS THAT LIKE HOW DEAR YOU
BELIEVE THERE IS AN OMNIPOTENT
GOD WHO COULD ACTUALLY LOVE YOU
AND CARE FOR YOU.
BUT MORE BROADLY THAN THAT, WE
SEE THIS CYNICAL PATTERN
WHENEVER THERE IS A MASS
MURDERER AND I HAVE TO SAY WE
HAVE HAD A WAY TO MANY OF THESE
MASS MURDERERS.
I REPRESENTED TEXAS IN THE
SENATE FOR NINE YEARS NOW.
I HAVE BEEN SANTA FE
HIGH SCHOOL, LESS THAN AN HOUR
AWAY FROM MY HOME.
I WAS DOWN AT SANTA FE
HIGH SCHOOL WITH AN HOUR OF THAT
SHOOTING.
IT WAS HORRIFIC, THE CRAZED
MADMAN WHO MURDERED THOSE KIDS.
EL PASO, THE CRAZED RACIST BIGOT
WHO MURDERED THE PEOPLE AT THAT
WALMART, I WAS THERE FOR THAT.
DALLAS, 15 POLICE OFFICERS WERE
MURDERED BY A RADICAL LEFTIST, I
WAS THERE FOR THAT I HAVE TO
TELL YOU SUTHERLAND SPRINGS, THE
WORST CHURCH SUITING IN U.S.
HISTORY, I WAS THERE THE DAY
AFTER THE SHOOTING IN THAT
SANCTUARY, I SAW WITH MY OWN
EYES THE BLOOD AND SHATTERED
GLASS ON THE AGONY AND THE
INCREDIBLE LOVE OF THAT
COMMUNITY.
THERE HAVE BEEN TO MANY OF THESE
AND WE NEED TO STOP THEM BUT THE
DEMOCRATS PROPOSAL EVERY TIME IS
ALWAYS THE SAME WHICH IS TAKE
AWAY GUNS FROM LAW-ABIDING
CITIZENS.
IF THAT IS THEIR POLITICAL
AGENDA EVERY SINGLE DAY, IT
DOESN'T WORK, AND IN FACT IT
MAKES IT WORSE BECAUSE IT
DISARMS THE POTENTIAL VICTIMS
AND MAKES THEM VULNERABLE TO
CRIMINALS.
IF YOU WANT TO STOP THEM, WHAT
WORKS IS YOU TARGET THE BAD
GUYS.
YOU GO AFTER FELONS AND
FUGITIVES AMONG THOSE WITH
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS TO STOP
THEM FROM GETTING GUNS AND WHEN
THEY TRY TO ILLEGALLY BUY A
FIREARM, YOU LOCK THEM UP AND
PUT THEM IN JAIL AND BACK IN
2013, I INTRODUCED LEGISLATION
THAT TARGETED THE BAD GUYS AND
DIRECT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
TO PROSECUTE FELONS AND
FUGITIVES THAT TRY TO ILLEGALLY
BUY GUNS.
THE DEMOCRATS IN 2013
FILIBUSTERED, GOT 52 VOTES ON
THE FLOOR OF THE SENATE, NINE
DEMOCRATS VOTED FOR IT SO IT WAS
THE MOST BIPARTISAN SUPPORT OF
ANY OF THE COMPREHENSIVE
LEGISLATION AND YET HERE HE READ
IN THE DEMOCRATS, CHUCK SCHUMER
AND THE REST OF THE LIBERALS
FILIBUSTERED IT, HE DIDN'T PASS.
I'LL TELL YOU IF IT HAD PASSED,
THERE WAS A VERY GOOD CHANCE
SUTHERLAND SPRINGS WOULDN'T HAVE
HAPPENED BECAUSE THE CRIMINAL
WHO HAD COMMITTED A FELONY AND
WAS INELIGIBLE TO BUY GUNS,
NEVER REPORTED HIS CONVICTION TO
THE BACKGROUND DATABASE AND WHEN
HE TRIED TO ILLEGALLY BUY THE
GUN, HIS CONVICTION WASN'T THERE
AND HE MURDERED THOSE PEOPLE.
IF IT HAD PASSED, THEY WOULD'VE
PROSECUTED HIM, WOULD'VE PUT HIM
IN JAIL AND HE WOULD HAVE BEEN
IN A JAIL CELL INSTEAD OF IN
THAT BEAUTIFUL SANCTUARY.
>> Sean: CURRENTLY IS THE
DEMOCRATS ALSO WHEN WE WERE
WATCHING BRICKS AND ROCKS AND
BOTTLES AND FROZEN WATER BOTTLES
AND MOLOTOV COCKTAILS AND NEARLY
3,000 COPS INJURED, 30 PEOPLE
KILLED, ARSON, LOOTING, TAKING
OVER OF POLICE PRECINCTS,
BURNING THEM TO THE GROUND,
ALLOWING CITY BLOCKS TO BE TAKEN
OVER, AUTONOMOUS ZONES, SUMMER
OF LOVE, SPAGHETTI POTLUCK
DINNERS, ARE THEY THE SAME ONES
THAT WERE TELLING US EVERY DAY
THAT THESE ARE NOT RIOTS, THESE
ARE PEACEFUL PROTESTS, THAT'S
WHAT I REMEMBER FROM LAST
SUMMER.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT AND
THESE ARE RICH LIBERALS WHO HAVE
THEIR OWN SECURITY DETAIL WOULD
SAY THAT YOU SHOULDN'T BE ABLE
TO PROTECT YOUR OWN FAMILY.
WE HAD A HEARING THAT IN 2020,
THE RATE OF GUN BUYING WENT UP
DRAMATICALLY AND IT MAY NOT
PARTICULARLY AMONG MINORITY
COMMUNITIES, HISPANICS AND
ASIAN-AMERICANS AND ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS I ASKED AT THE HEARING
WAS HOW MUCH DID THE RIOTS OF
2020, ANTIFA, BLACK LIVES MATTER
RIOTS THAT WERE BURNING OUR
CITIES LOOTING STORES AND
MURDERING POLICE OFFICERS, HOW
MUCH OF THAT CONTRIBUTED AND THE
WITNESS TESTIMONY WAS QUITE A
BIT.
I COULD TELL YOU WHEN HOUSTON
WHEN THESE RIOTS WERE HAPPENING,
THERE WERE STORIES ABOUT HOW
VIOLENT MOBS WERE GOING TO COME
INTO THE SUBURBS AND RAID
PEOPLE'S HOMES AND IN HOUSTON
THAT WOULD NOT WORK OUT WELL
BECAUSE PEOPLE BELIEVE IN THE
RIGHT TO KEEP AND BEAR ARMS AND
IF YOU COME AFTER THEIR
FAMILIES, YOU'RE GOING TO MEET
THE BUSINESS END OF A FIREARM
AND THAT IS A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT
FOR TEXANS AND THE
BILL OF RIGHTS.
EVERY YEAR, FIREARMS ARE USED IN
A DEFENSIVE SITUATION TO STOP A
CRIMINAL ABOUT A MILLION TIMES A
YEAR AND THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO
TAKE THAT AWAY WHICH ENDANGERS
YOU AND YOUR FAMILY AND THEY
OPPOSED TARGETING THE BAD GUYS
IN THE CRIMINALS.
YOU WANT TO STOP GUN VIOLENCE?
GO AFTER THE BAD GUYS, THAT'S
WHAT WORKS AND PROTECTS THE
SECOND AMENDMENT.
>> Sean: AMAZING HOW JOE BIDEN
THIN